why are we celebrating her body why does
it matter that's what I'm saying like
why aren't we celebrating her music
because it isn't gonna be awesome if she
gets diabetes
just days after sparking controversy
with those comments about Queen Liz Oh
Jillian Michaels shocked the internet
again with this picture you will learn
for what I have been through welp you
know on Thursday the 45 year old trainer
shared this throwback shot of herself
wearing a blue striped shirt Bermuda
shorts and a white headband alongside
the caption here's me at 5 feet tall and
175 pounds if I can do it anyone can
share your story the post comes smack
dab in the middle of her ongoing drama
with Liz o which all started when
Jillian made some comments that lots of
fans thought were an attempt to body
shame the truth hurts singer
jyllian recently sat down with
BuzzFeed's a.m. to DM and when the convo
turned to Liz's messages of body
positivity and self-love Jillian made it
pretty clear she wasn't feeling it why
are we celebrating her body why does it
matter that's what I'm saying like why
aren't we celebrating her music because
it isn't gonna be awesome if she gets
diabetes yeah she just said that well
I'm just being honest like I love her
music like my kid loves her music but
there's never a moment where I'm like
and I'm so glad that she's overweight
like why do we why do I even care why is
it my job to care about her weight mm
okay I've been working my stuff for a
long time everybody knows the people who
know know and right now I just feel like
it's what we deserve naturally Liz those
fans were quick to come to her defense
then Jillian released a statement saying
that we are all beautiful worthy and
equally deserving adding I also feel
strongly that we love ourselves enough
to acknowledge there are serious health
consequences that come with obesity well
that's when Lisa chimed in posting these
pics of her fabulousness in a gold
bikini alongside the caption I love you
you are beautiful you can do anything
repeat oh and this video that may or may
not be about Jillian my name is in your
mouth so was my pitch enjoy the flavor
earlier this month et caught up with
Jillian's former Biggest Loser co-star
Bob Harper who weighed in on the whole
thing I've never met Liz oh I can't
comment on her her health all I know is
that I love her and I love her music and
she can play a mean flute so Liz oh just
took a DNA test and turns out she's 100%
that tweet all lovin know and you can
count on et to break all the latest
lizzo news so make sure to keep it
locked right here until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]